okay hello and welcome to pie dear girl
2021
my name is zaki i'm very happy to be
here and be your host for this session i
would like to now welcome
the coders
to be our speech and the topic is why
interactive data visualization matters
for data science in platform
and nicolas
is 50
of product and head of data
visualization of paddy here's the paddy
expert we had pivot table and pivot
table dot js data analysis ii is
studying in engineer and university of
toronto and previously worked in travel
demanding modeling and for economic and
tech communication and technology and
healthcare analysis so let me move the
time to the nic
ricardo please thank you
hello everyone from montreal my name is
nicholas christian and i am the head of
data visualization at plotley
i am really excited to give this talk
today uh on why interactive data
visualization matters for data science
in python um this isn't really a sort of
plotly focused talk this is a bit more
of an abstract higher level talk
because as i uh as i talk to folks in
the data science community um you know
as part of my job uh i often encounter
this attitude that oh you know
interactive data visualization isn't for
me it's sort of something i do when my
boss
really needs it or when i'm presenting
my results to somebody else but
here you know here at place we do
serious work uh we don't we don't need
interactive data visualization and i
think that's kind of a shame because i
think i think there's a lot more value
to to interactive vis
than that attitude sort of admits and so
i wanted to give this talk sort of lay
out a clear case for why uh interactive
data visualization sort of matters
um
so because this is not just to talk
about plotly i'll be talking about a
bunch of different libraries here
and all of my materials are available
here at this url
and i'll be in slack a little bit later
answering questions all day long if i
don't get to your questions although i
will try and leave some time at the end
so to kick us off um uh i'll sort of uh
uh quote richard hamming who's a
computer scientist uh his his credo sort
of in the 60s was that the purpose of
computing is insight not numbers and
this is sort of an endlessly remixable
quote i think uh you know we could apply
this to data science the purpose of data
science is insight not models um and
certainly this uh this credo was taken
up by by data visualization researchers
in the 90s um ben schneiderman said the
purpose of visualization is insight not
pictures
and sort of my take on this that i'm
going to use to to introduce this talk
is to say
that interactive data visualization
isn't just something you make as in oh i
made an interactive data visualization
yesterday it's also something that you
do as in i did some interactive data
visualization yesterday
and that's the what i'd like to focus on
sort of uh interactive database as a
process rather than as an artifact
so to kind of cut to the chase uh here's
the answer to the question that i posed
in the title of my talk interactive data
visualization matters for data science
in python
because it can help get to more insights
faster
and that's what i'd like to kind of try
to show you through this talk
so here's a basic framework that i'll be
using for thinking about interactive
data vis for data science and python uh
we've got a data scientist we've got a
python system and an interactive
database is actually this loop it's this
process where the data scientist sort of
does something sends some action to the
python system and the python system
responds with a data view so a data view
could be a table it could be a graph it
could be a map whatever it is uh and
sort of so long as we're engaging in
this loop we're doing interactive data
visualization in python
and i wanted to kind of talk about uh
four levels of interactivity um so i've
kind of made up this framework for for
this talk but hopefully it will be it'll
be useful for people
so the first level i'm going to call
level zero
and uh and maybe you know people roll
their eyes a little bit but the first
level i want to talk about is sort of
this loop of edit code get new view and
i think this is actually something that
the most data scientists are using
python kind of do all the time so let me
give you a quick example of what this
looks like i'm here going to load up
seabourn and some tips data in jupiter
lab
and i'm going to do what data scientists
do kind of do all day long so i've got a
data set where each row
is a restaurant bill and i'm going to
make a plot here's a plot of the tip
versus the total bill and here's the
interaction part i can go and edit this
code say
hue equals smoker
hit shift enter and now i have a new
data view so that was the loop the the
action was me sending some code and um
and the reaction from the system was was
the new data view and i can keep going i
can get some lines on here by saying lm
plot uh and i can sort of see that the
trend is a little bit different you know
the average tip ratio is is different
for smokers let's say maybe not
statistically significantly i can add
some columns
um i can add some rows
uh and that kind of uh sorry
um
and uh that to kind of facet the data
and now i can kind of see like oh maybe
this is kind of a weird outlier
uh this is uh you know an interesting
trend in version
so
uh this is something that uh that that
you can do and you can kind of drive
insights by iterating through the
machine
uh through this process
so that's level zero i've called it
level zero because it's kind of the
baseline and what i like about this is
that anybody who says to me that they
don't really like interactive is it's
kind of doing it anyway but i don't make
a big point of this
um so so the core sort of structure of
my argument about why interactive vis
matters is that as you progress through
the levels you can go faster and faster
and get more insights so let's get to
level one
level one of interactivity is basically
you manipulate a widget and the view
changes so let's go back to jupiter
i'm going to use the plotly library here
i'm going to load up some time series
data
and then let's make
a plot with my time series data and i've
got a i've got a rolling average smooth
here
and my my rolling average window is five
and let's say i want to play with that
so i make it six okay i make it
seven
okay
so i can kind of change it by using
level zero interactions but i'm spending
most of my time looking at my code and
making sure i'm typing the right thing
so a faster way to do this a more sort
of deeply interactive way to do this
um is to use something like uh the
interact decorator from ipi widgets um
here all i do is i declare i wrap my my
same code in a in a function
and i pi widgets automatically makes a
slider for me so this is a widget and
now
as i play with this widget as i drag it
around i can kind of dial in the the
curve quite quickly and so let's say
that actually
the smooth that i'm looking for has this
parameter 10. i was able to get that
really fast just by just by moving that
slider around um and if i want to i can
then go back to my code and sort of bake
that in
so that's
a typical kind of level one interaction
where i'm manipulating something that's
outside the view to change the view
and the interact system is pretty
powerful you can use it to build you
know in just like three lines of python
here um a little system that lets you
interactively sort of color this thing
by different
by different variables here what i'm
doing is i'm changing the mapping of
what's what's being mapped to x y and
color with these three little drop downs
so the ipi widget system is really
powerful
another quick example of what a level
one interaction might be
is a system called jupyter pivot table
which which i authored a number of years
ago and here i'm loading the same pandas
data frame and i get a nice little ui
and i can build a table interactively
you know i can kind of drag things
around here
a table is a is a totally legitimate
data view but you notice i'm not really
interacting with the table here i'm just
kind of playing with these widgets
and so again
i can do this interaction i can kind of
map what i figured out that i wanted to
put in the ui into the code
and kind of get this view
back out
so so much for level one um i think
folks who who came to my talk and to
hear about you know interactive database
kind of are more interested in the good
stuff like what happens when you click
on the graph
so that that is level two level two is
when you manipulate the view itself and
the view changes
so let's go look at some examples of
that uh if i make this sort of fairly
typical uh plot that you see in data
science um in graphing library demos all
the time this is a data set where
there's one dot per country
and i've got gdp per capita on the
x-axis life expectancy on the y-axis and
so here's a really typical kind of level
two interaction when i'm manipulating
the view let's zoom in let's zoom in on
this little crowded area here
so all i did was sort of a drag select
and it zoomed in
and in terms of a level zero interaction
in terms of what that what what it is to
express that in code it's really simple
right i'm just changing the x the range
of the x axis and the range of the y
axis but you got to admit that it's
actually much faster and more intuitive
to be able to just do a drag rather than
to think like okay i want to look at
this area this area is roughly here and
then it's actually here and then i have
to go type and then like oh no i got it
wrong like this loop is just faster
and i'm able to kind of get to what i
wanted to understand about the
relationship between these dots much
more quickly
plotly affords a number of different
ways to play with the limits you can
kind of drag the axis around here you
can grab the corners move them around
you can even double click in the corners
and actually set exact values if you
want
another type of level two interaction
that i can show you here is filtering so
i can hide a series by clicking on the
legend item uh i can bring it back i can
focus on a series just by double
clicking on that legend item
so again
easy to do in code just go and like edit
the code and change the filter of the
pandas data frame that i filled in but
this is sort of much more direct i see
the blue i want the blue i double click
on the blue i've got it that loop is
much faster and i'm less thinking about
how to go back to my code and more
thinking about what i actually want to
do with my data
so
folks who have used plotly before might
be confused by why there's no tooltips i
turned them off for the the first part
of this uh this section but let me turn
them back on you actually have to work
to turn them off because they're there
by default
and and to me
tool tips are sort of the real killer
app of level two type interactions so a
tooltip
sort of formally is two things there's a
hover interaction i'm moving my mouse
over a point and then the visualization
system is responding by putting an
annotation at the place where i
where i am hovering and so in this
particular case um i am hovering over
over the vietnam data point and i've got
this little tooltip
so why do i think that the tooltip is
sort of the unsung hero of database
to me
it's basically because
um
basically because
of two kind of contradictory things one
a tooltip is able to decode information
more quickly and more precisely that was
encoded in the in the database so each
dot here i've got four uh four columns
of data mapped into it i've got the x
axis the exposition is the gdp y
position is life expectancy color is the
continent and size is the population and
i can get kind of an overview i can see
that there is a roughly linear
relationship against this log scale but
it's really hard to pick out precise
values unless
i mouse over and boom i can actually
read the exact values and i can read
life expectancy uh to three decimal
places if i want so this is a way that
tooltips can help you decode information
that's been encoded
so that yeah you could probably you know
use a ruler but you don't have to
and the second kind of contradictory
point why i think that tooltips are so
so powerful is because they can contain
information that wasn't in the original
visualization so here i've got the name
of the dot
now i could have just put the names of
all the dots uh on on every dot and this
would be this very crowded thing and i
might have to zoom in to actually see
anything but in this particular case i
can just kind of wander my mouse and
sort of look at like okay boom this big
dot is china this big dot is is uh sorry
china and india um
uh and so i've actually put data into
the tooltip that wasn't in the original
uh in the original viz and that allows
me to you know if i had additional data
columns about um
about these countries like i could
encode it and sort of wander my mouse
around and say hmm you know maybe
there's a maybe there's a relationship
here with a variable x and then i could
switch back to a level zero type
interaction to go uh to go map that in
some systems even let you put images and
tool tips or further graphs into
tooltips so so to me this is really the
kind of thing that's extremely difficult
to do with a level zero or level one
interaction as you know if i want to see
what's this point boom
okay it's south africa if i wanted to
put a conditional annotation on this
with a level zero interaction it would
take me you know five minutes okay a
couple of minutes
so you know panning and zooming uh
filtering hovering what else can i do
with a level two interaction
uh
let me kind of drive the point home on
on panning and zooming
here is a map it's kind of hard not to
interact with it actually it just draws
you right in um this is a map of
earthquake data
and at high zoom levels you know things
are sort of smoothed out and when i zoom
in with my scroll wheel that's the
action the reaction is to zoom in i can
hover i've got the date of the
earthquake uh so this is another really
good example of sort of um
how you can dive right into a data set
with a with a level two attraction and
that's not going to be surprising to
anyone who's used you know google maps
or something like that
if you've got any kind of hierarchical
data you can represent it perhaps in a
visual representation that allows you to
drill down so here's the same data as
the first example again i've got
countries within continents i can click
on a continent to drill in i can click
to drill back out if i had multiple
levels of hierarchy like a file system
or a decision tree i'd be able to kind
of keep keep drilling down
i can hover over each of these these
items to get the exact values out
the gdp per capita is here in the hover
label
i've added it so
this is another example of a sort of
level two interaction
and then the final level two interaction
i want to show
is sort of selection so here is a
parallel coordinates chart each line on
this chart each zigzagging line
represents a car uh along one two three
four five six you know roughly ten um
ten dimensions um and so i can trace
sort of individual lines and see overall
patterns but i can use a level two
interaction to kind of think about that
so let's see like is there something
about expensive cars okay so expensive
cars tend to have you know low miles per
gallon a high weight
um
and maybe a high number of cylinders i
can i even drag these things around so
let's see if the miles per gallon thing
holds okay yep they tend to be you know
inversely correlated um
so these are types of level two
interactions where i'm just you know
changing the visualization to sort of
support uh
asking and answering questions in a much
faster way than with level zero or level
so back to my framework there's one more
level uh level three is sort of a mashup
of the first two it's basically using
one view as a widget to manipulate
another so let me show that because it's
it's easier to show than to talk about
um
actually sorry before i get to level
three i did wanna to uh to point out
something about level two let me
interrupt myself
level two is not something that you have
to switch to a library like python to do
here's an example of using uh the
matplotlib widget uh in conjunction with
seaborne to uh to do some of the same
things so here i am i've got a seaborn
plot it's right here and you know i can
do hovers uh with seabourn they're
conditional annotations i can resize
this plot make it bigger i can switch to
a zoom box i can zoom
i can turn that off and go back to
hovering
so
uh you know part of the point i'm trying
to make here is not that you have to use
plot lead to do interactive data
visualization is that data interactive
data visualization is useful and there's
a lot of ways to do it in python
so back to my
to my level 3 here
let me show a simple example from a
library called holoviews
using the bokeh data visualization
library
here i've got a data set of unemployment
by county in the state of texas
i've got a table i've got a map here on
my map i can i can do the typical hover
interaction the table i can do some
level two interactions so i can sort the
table
and then the level three interaction is
if i click on a county it lights up if i
shift click on you know the top
n uh high unemployment counties they all
light up
in fact i can make a drag selections or
i can make a drag selection
on the map and have those rows light up
uh in in the table so this is the kind
of thing it's sort of like a super set
of the hover if you wanted to say like
what do these counties have in common
you could set up a table here that gave
you a summary statistic um
and sort of make a selection over here
and very quickly kind of compare and
drill down uh in into your data so this
is a typical level three interaction um
another database library in python which
i really love is called altair um here
i've got you know a number of lines of
code uh that produce this sort of four
panel vis
and what i can do is i can make a
selection so here i've got
a scatter plot of of cars again
miles per gallon versus horsepower i've
got my nice tool tip i can see the year
that the car was made in and the actual
model name to identify individual points
typical level two and then the level
three interaction is i can make a drag
selection and uh these summaries here
the mean acceleration for these cars the
mean weight in in pounds and then how
many cars there are by cylinder and as i
move this thing around i can kind of
explore the relationship and so you can
see that actually cars with higher
horsepower tended to um
to have actually lower acceleration uh
and weigh more uh and so this is maybe
something that you can discover via this
interaction then you go and back to a
level zero interaction and make another
scatter plot to kind of explore that
correlation more directly
final level three interaction plotly
here i've got a scatter plot again of
miles per gallon versus horsepower and
then this fancy parallel categories
chart but instead of making selections
over here i can paint so i'm going to
select these
high horsepower
cars and paint them in red and i'm going
to select these low horsepower cars and
paint them in blue
and i can see interestingly enough that
actually all the blue ones uh have front
wheel drive and most of the red ones
here have rear-wheel drive um and so i
can kind of you know go and explore this
data in an even richer way than just by
making a single selection by essentially
making multiple selections and painting
i can reset this whole thing by painting
everything gray and let's actually try
and see you know let's make all the real
rear wheel drive ones red okay
all the front wheel drive one's blue
okay and yeah there's a sort of rough
relationship that the blue ones tend to
be over here on the left and the red
ones tend to be here on the right so
this is kind of an ad hoc bespoke vis
that that was built you know in just a
few lines of python code under under 50
that enables a number of different types
of interactions
so that's that's it for level three and
the the core argument that i'm making
essentially that you can go faster and
get deeper insights when you go to
further levels but note that you don't
have to go to level one to use level two
you know basically any chart that you
make in um in plotley or or bokeh will
have hovering and panning and zooming
and it's pretty easy to turn it on
in matplotlib
so the thing that i like to think about
is that interactive database can be to
analysis what a jig is to woodworking so
if you don't do any woodworking a jig is
essentially a little tool that's made to
measure often on the spot with scrap
materials it's not part of the final
output so if you're making a beautiful
cabinet you might make yourself a jig
which is like a guide to help guide your
cuts or something that you clamp onto
your piece of wood to make it to allow
you to move faster and more confidently
but you don't actually sell it or you
don't actually mount it on your wall
like the beautiful cabinet you're making
but you make it with the same tools and
materials in the same shop
you're making this jig you're making
this cabinet and you've made it for
yourself to allow yourself to move
faster and so i think that interactive
database the examples that i've been
giving are of that class that you can
uh you can quickly pull together a
visualization tense or the specific
question that you're answering it
doesn't have to be part of the output uh
that you that that you know you
communicate to your stakeholders this is
sort of the
visualization the purpose of
visualization is insight not pictures
the idea isn't always just to make the
picture it's to get the insight and then
move on so the purpose of the jig is to
make the cut and then move on
but you can in fact
make interactive is
accessible to everyone right so here
i've got a data scientist and a
non-coder who also wants to participate
in the process of interactive
visualization and so in my little levels
hierarchy levels one two and three don't
require any coding
and and that means that we can bring in
more people into the process of data
interactive database if we can build
python systems that are accessible to
them so in if in about an hour there's
another session that i'm participating
in called the python dashboarding
shootout showdown
which is going to be a fun and
informative session
where i will be talking with some
representatives from
three other python libraries
other than plotly dash for making python
systems that essentially bring level one
two and three interactions to non-data
scientists
so please please join that if you can
and if you're watching this later on
youtube trying to find the recording
because
to me the skills needed to build these
jigs that we can use for ourselves as
data scientists are the same skills that
are needed
to build systems that bring in non-data
scientists and and non-non-coders into
the process and i think that that can be
really important and powerful
so before i open up for questions i'm
going to address uh two common
objections uh to to to why you know
interactive database uh is is uh matters
a lot in in data science so the most
common one is sort of who has the time
and i hear that you know we're busy
people we know how to use whatever it is
we're doing uh why you know we don't
have time to learn fancy new
technologies um and my my response to
this is basically that you know the
whole point of jig and woodworking is to
to move faster and more confidently uh
to have to do less rework um
and so and so it's worth the investment
uh i i've purposely chosen examples uh
from the documentation of all the
libraries that i that i uh i showed off
um and they're all examples that are you
know sort of under 50 lines of python
fairly easy to remix and adapt um and so
generally you know
the core objection that folks will have
is sort of it takes too much time and
the value is too low and i hope that
through this talk i've been able to kind
of maybe shift that balance for some of
you to say okay actually this stuff
doesn't take a lot of code it doesn't
take a lot of time and the value is
really high
and so that's one one response to sort
of who has the time
the second uh core objection that's
quite a principled one
is reproducibility and i do want to
acknowledge that one
directly
um it is
it can be quite difficult to make
reproducible code from a level two or
three interactions so you know when i
was painting in red and blue if i
actually wanted to capture that in code
to be able to reproduce it uh that's a
little bit challenging i do acknowledge
that i don't think it's a reason to
throw out interactive is altogether
to me it's a challenge it's sort of the
frontier
you know maybe
tools like bamboo lib and maito which i
don't have time to show off here
should be the new standard what those
tools that you do is they let you make
visualizations and then there's a button
that shows you the python code that
would uh that would reproduce
respond here and then you know we have
five minutes
we just like go to the question um
let me just let me just get to through
my one last slide please
um
so uh you know the the challenge that i
would put to to my fellow tool makers is
that more systems should uh should
actually expose the code um
that uh that can be used to reproduce
the visualizations that interactions
produce because this is why we use
python right to automate and to
reproduce uh and maybe more notebook
systems could have first class support
for injecting code back into uh back
into the
flow so to sum up interactive database
matters for data science and python
because it can help get to more insights
faster that's my core claim um
and uh if anyone wants to go deeper i've
got some
links to some academic papers about sort
of deep thinking about what interaction
is and what it can be
all of the materials for this slide are
available at this link and you can get
in touch with me
at the url or on twitter i'll be on
slack there's a slack channel as well
and i've got a few minutes for questions
now
okay um let's get some questions from
the audience so
someone said um on his experience
practice is the best interactive funding
library however on the same time it's
the most comp computational demanding is
any plan to lighting it
um i would be i'd be happy to kind of
engage with you i mean yes we uh
we're always working to make the library
better um there's there's lots of sort
of technical challenges uh involved in
that and we welcome any contribution or
sort of uh community engagement to help
that
okay okay and one more question
in there is which resources can you
recommend to learn better pilot
um so check out this link right here
i've got all my notebooks right there in
every notebook that i showed i have a
link at the top of the notebook to the
documentation file that i used so for
every one of these notebooks if you
scroll to the very top here there's a
link to the official documentation page
from that library for how to do it
and then basically you know this is this
is kind of how i would recommend
learning these things read the
documentation
ask yourself for any given situation
you're in for whatever data science task
you're you're currently tackling is
there a jig is there something that
would make this easier if you find
yourself sort of machine gunning through
code viz code viz code vis ask yourself
what would make this easier and and say
like oh you know that that talk that i
saw nick give go go go get that
two-liner about the uh the ipython
interact and build yourself a slider and
get your insight faster um so so this
talk is sort of uh how i'm trying to uh
to raise awareness of these uh of these
tools and these capabilities um but but
to me the core mission for this talk is
to sort of raise people's awareness that
this is a technique that you can use um
and then the actual how you do it which
library you use
is is sort of sort of up to you
okay last question
do you think interactive visualization
can help porno issue with the data
itself have you ever considered way to
visualize problems with the data like
missing data or
duplicate for example
yeah so they're um
you know one of the core core tensions
in database is that you're really
visualizing the data that you've got and
if your data has problems uh that's
gonna show up in the viz now uh if you
assume that your data you know uh is is
perfect and you you draw conclusions
from your from your graphic uh you may
draw uh erroneous conclusions so the
first um the first sort of tool is
really critical thinking and asking
yourself you know is this viz
does this show about the data what i
expect to see in the data um and yeah
there's definitely you can use the the
typical techniques of data visualization
to
uh to detect um you know problems in the
data you can say well you know i expect
this number to be between one and a
hundred you make a histogram and you've
got numbers and a thousand maybe this
thing's been multiplied by ten um
you can you can explicitly uh you know
sort of count uh values that are null
and and use use typical database tools
to to diagnose those problems so um
definitely a lot of thought uh has gone
into this in in the viz community uh
most of the tools that i've shown uh
exist to visualize your data as you've
got it so if there are nulls in the data
that will show up uh in in whatever way
uh each library uh sort of handles those
okay our time is over career county move
the discussion to the snap or gator
times thank you the corners for your
talk for
being part of the pi data global 2021
thank you so much